Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
We finally got some good news
about Spider-Man 4
We learned some of the characters
that are coming back
How this is all going to work
with Avengers 6
Secret Wars,
the big reboot that Marvel is doing
The MCU and what Tom Holland future as
Spider-Man is actually going to look like
And what's going on with live action
Miles Morales
We do still have Spider-Man Beyond
the Spider-Verse coming out in 2025.
Now because it was delayed
just a little bit.
And we've got the Spider-Man 2 game
with Miles Morales, which just came out
is connected to the Spider-Verse movies.
So we'll explain
what's going on with everything.
And because they just released the game,
we're giving away a couple of copies.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just let me know
what you want them to do with live action.
Miles Morales on the video,
starting with the big stuff
first, of course, Tom Holland is back,
even though there's an actor strike
right now as of me posting this video,
he's signed his new Spider-Man deal.
Four more movies before the Actors
Strike started earlier this year.
That was for the next trilogy of movies.
Spider-Man four, five and six in some non
Spider-Man Marvel movies like Avengers,
five, in Avengers, six,
that's one of the few reasons why Tom
Holland didn't do The Voice of Spider-Man
during the What If series in
why he's not doing The Voice
during the Spider-Man
freshman year series.
that'd be the same actor
that did Spider-Man during the
what if series like he'll just continue
playing animated Spider-Man.
but freshman year
will feature the MCU Spider-Man.
It'll just be a variant of the character
in another universe.
So like,
all the characters will be just like,
a little bit different,
but it'll be based on MCU.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
that's actually going to be dropping
at some point during 2025, the same year,
the Spider-Man four supposed to come out
also the same year,
the Beyond the Spider-Verse is coming out.
So the like three big Spider-Man
things that are coming out that year right
now, 2025 Spider-Man
fans are going to be eating good,
despite the actors strike still going on.
As Amy posting this video
today, Sony and Marvel are still supposed
to begin production of Spider-Man four
by the end of this year, 2023,
so they can release the movie
by summer 2025.
That's the current release date
they're trying to hit
but Spider-Man four coming out in 2025
would mean that it comes out
right after the new Fantastic Four movie.
But before Avengers five, Qing Dynasty
right now, Marvel hasn't said what
a lot of it's
2025 movies, 2026 movies are going to be
besides like Fantastic Four
in the next Avengers movies,
They'll be at least two other
Marvel movies they release in 2025.
So they'll name those pretty soon.
Probably going to be like the Blade movie,
maybe the Iron Man Armor Wars movie.
We'll see. the better, much
of recent delays because of the strike.
So Marvel just hit the pause button
on announcing new projects.
probably one of the biggest surprises
or maybe it's not a surprise to you.
Jon Watts is expected to come back
and direct Spider-Man four.
I thought that he had left
because he wanted to do other stuff.
But this is a couple of years ago
when Spider-Man far from home, came out.
Now, like it's been a couple of years,
he was briefly attached to the brand new
Fantastic Four movie.
but then he did the Star Wars
Skeleton Crew series with Jude Law.
That's done, by the way.
They finished it.
They'll release it sometime in 2024.
It's connected to the Mandalorian
in the Ahsoka series.
the reason why he did that Star Wars
series is actually
because of his relationship with Jon
Favreau, who's happy.
Hogan In all of the Spider-Man movies,
they were actually talking.
and because he's kind of like
the Kevin Feige
of that Mandalorian Star Wars universe.
He's like, Hey, why don't you come
have a Star War with me?
And he was like,
okay, sure, I'll come to a Star Wars
series will probably get a trailer
for that sometime early next year.
my assumption is that Sony
and Marvel were so worried
about all the recent issues
they've had with quality control,
with the movies,
the series during the pandemic
era filmmaking, that they wanted
a guaranteed thing with their new director
in Spider-Man four.
Like they wanted to start off this
new Spider-Man trilogy on a really strong
but the last two Spider-Man movies
earned over $1,000,000,000.
Spider-Man
No Way Home earned almost $2 billion.
So Sony is like, Please, please come back.
They probably backed up a dump
truck of money to John Watts house,
like come back and do this for us
just to get us
started off on the right foot.
No idea.
If he's also going to direct
Spider-Man five and Spider-Man
six, it's a little too soon to tell.
Here's
where we get to the returning characters
just beyond Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
And a lot of these details
were actually revealed
by Amy Pascal, like the lead producer
on the Sony side of things
way earlier this year at the Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse premiere.
So we've actually known
about some of the details for a while.
is that Zendaya is coming
back as her version of MJ
should be a main character again, despite
Doctor Strange, a Spell and everything
that happened in the Spider-Man
No Way Home ending in Post-Credits scenes.
she's just continue
to be part of his orbit
while he's trying to be Spider-Man
and be Peter Parker and go to college
during the day.
early theory
is that he'll probably wind up
having to save her a couple of times
and he'll be around her during the day
and things between them will play out
similarly to the way they did before,
where she starts to notice
weird inconsistencies and coincidences.
And she figures out that he is Spider-Man
all by herself.
Again, the only way to explain her
being a main character again,
because the movie's
going to take place in the New York City
area would be if she loses any chance
of a scholarship to MIT in the US,
can't afford to pay tuition and has to go
to a local New York City college
because that's a pretty common story
There are a lot of my friends in real life
that had that problem too,
like really smart people
that got into Ivy League colleges
but just couldn't pay the massive,
massive tuition.
Peter was getting his GED
at the end of the movie
because our memory of him was erased.
this was like he never attended school.
That's why he had to get the GED
in the first place.
You know, use that
to get into a local New York City college,
like the comics and like the Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man movies.
the other big news is from Kevin Feige.
And he revealed that the plot of Daredevil
Born Again, will figure heavily
into the events of Spider-Man four
Marvel actually just hit the big reset
button on Daredevil Born Again.
They're still going to eventually make
the series
bill look like completely different
from what they were making before this.
So Daredevil Born Again, had been delayed
just a little bit.
cannot wait to see Daredevil
and Spider-Man team up to fight Kingpin
and for King to try and squish him
some Spider-Man Of course
I will do videos for everything
and I will do videos for all the episodes.
When they start releasing them,
Kingpin isn't meant to be
the main villain of Spider-Man four.
He'll just be doing his thing,
trying to get rid of vigilantes
like Spider-Man or calling Spider-Man
a vigilante.
Technically, he's a hero,
but he's kind of like a vigilante.
Like Daredevil
So Spider-Man will be dealing with that.
Like he'll be on the outs with the law
because they'll be coming after him,
trying to get rid of vigilantes
while he's also trying to defeat
the regular villains in the movie.
is a very Spider-Man,
very daredevil type of problem to have.
Like, how do you save everyone
when everyone thinks
that you're the bad guy,
when technically that's not true?
Like,
how do you prove that you are the good guy
it all plays into the whole idea
that they're taking Spider-Man
four in a more friendly neighborhood.
Spider-Man direction away from all
the Iron Man high level Avengers stuff.
But he will still be in Avengers five,
Qing Dynasty and Secret Wars
and all that big stuff.
ages that they're taking the character
back to a more comic book
original Spider-Man type of territory,
less tech based Spider-Man,
really good examples of that were Tobey
Maguire, Spider-Man in Andrew Garfield's
versions of Spider-Man.
they also recently revealed that
they're making a live action Miles Morales
movie like Hot off the Presses
Live action Miles Morales and a Spider
Gwen spin off movie with Hailee Steinfeld,
the version of the character
there have been rumors in the past
that they were going to do live action.
Miles
Morales in the MCU during Spider-Man four
because the apartment that he moves into
has Hispanic neighbors.
So people were like, wait a minute,
is that Miles Morales family?
They just lives in his building with him.
we already know a version of Miles Morales
exists in the MCU during the movie
Spider-Man Across the Spider-Verse
MCU, Aaron Davis
also shows up in Spider-Man 2099 prison.
He had just become The Prowler
during Spider-Man homecoming.
So it's like in the time since then
he started wearing the prowler armor.
there was also a deleted scene
during Spider-Man Homecoming
where he specifically
mentions Miles Morales
that all took
place well before Avengers
Infinity War in the snap.
And there were a lot of theories
that they just used the five year
time jump to age, that version of Miles
Morales up a little bit faster.
Now, Shameik Moore, who also plays
Miles Morales in the Spider-Verse movies,
said that he is trying to get the job as
the live action version of Miles Morales.
Like I already play a version of him
and he's in his late twenties.
He's a little bit older,
but it wouldn't be hard
for them to play him a little bit younger.
I don't know if his comments
are meant to be a misdirect
and they're already planning to use him
as the live action version, or
they've already planned
on casting a completely different actor
because during Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse,
they mix so many live action
versions of Spider-Man into the movie
in related characters like MCU. Prowler.
it supports the theory that some of the
Spider-Verse versions of the characters
will just transition into live action
for Avengers Secret Wars cameos.
speaking of live action crossover
because she plays Kate Bishop.
She was also talking about her
version of Kate Bishop meeting,
the live action version of her spider
Gwen Let me know in the comments, though.
What do you want them to do with the live
action version of Miles Morales?
because they need a version of Spider-Man
for all these Sinister six spin offs
developing
like in the Morbius Post-Credits scene,
they talk about a version of Spider-Man.
They're mostly
talking about Tom Holland Spider-Man,
but they need a version of Spider-Man
for them to fight in those Sony
spin off movies.
still kind of hoping that
that winds up being Andrew Garfield.
But we'll see.
I know a lot of you were wondering
what Tom Holland's future in Marvel
is, that they're going to do a big soft
reboot with Avengers Secret Wars.
The whole idea
is that he's going to stay as Spider-Man.
Nothing's going to change about that.
They're not really changing his back story
with the soft reboot
or anything like that.
They're just using that to retain some of
the other characters, recast actors.
If they need to Bring back
some core characters who are played
by actors who died in real life.
sort of like a big housecleaning
for Marvel
so that they can make the universe
look more like the true 616 universe
were like the X-Men, the Fantastic Four,
The Avengers characters
all coexisted on the same planet,
always the same time.
see you don't run into that problem.
Like during Avengers Endgame,
where people like,
How come the Eternals didn't help out
during Avengers Secret Wars?
How come the X-Men didn't help out
during Secret wars?
Where were they this whole time?
so for the most part, none of that is
going to affect Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
There's a bunch of big stuff
coming up My full Loki Season 2 Episode 4
Video will post later this week
after they release it,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that click here
for that video.
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
to learn about the big Marvel reboot
that's going to be happening.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!